step right up and let me show you today
how to install a new key fob
for your 2011 to 2013 silverado and up
everything from about 2011 to present
day you're gonna need a special device
to be able to
program a new key fob for your truck
everything lower than that there was a
setting in the truck you just press a
button and boom
you can program a new key pop to your
truck without her today because i have a
and all vehicles today you need a
certain program or you have to go to the
dealership to program a new key phone
new key fobs at the dealership can run
you up to 300 400
especially for the ones that have the
push to start feature luckily i just
have a turnkey
and it was low cost to find this option
i saw this option for this product at
an advanced auto power search in this
package of many shop edges lies the
product you are looking for right here
gm
2011 the 2015 they make ones that are
2015 to present day
that is also stated in 2020 2021 2022
20 40 and beyond looks almost oem but
you can tell by just the buttons alone
and then on the back
you got the programmer plugging in the
obd2 port it's only good for about three
to five uses because they want to limit
you that way they can sell more products
but then that contributes to more
e-waste which doesn't make sense to me
there are many places that take
electronics for recycle and that's what
i have to do once i use out this product
today i figured
because of the price i had to pick it up
least wasteful option would be going to
your dealership and getting one from
them
now dorman calls it a keyless entry
remote and that's what we'll call today
10 minutes installation that may
even be 10 seconds let's get this open i
already ripped it open up the finger a
couple times but hey we got it out
as i mentioned before if your vehicle is
older than 2011 especially a jam
would have been a button that you can
press right here to program a new key
fob without buying
this unit right here maybe we'll tamper
in this later see if we can hack the
ecm and try to get 150 more horsepower
of the truck bring him a new file you
have to program all your fobs at the
same time in a d
program as any other fobs now let's get
started to programming the new
key fob for your truck first step is to
close the
door and then lock all the doors to your
vehicle
insert your existing key into the
ignition and
turn power to the truck without starting
the next step is to locate your obd2
port
which should be right by the pedal area
of your truck or car is that not going
in there
once the program is inserted wait for a
chime or red lights on the programmer to
come on this will indicate that the unit
is ready to program the first remote
hold the lock and unlock button of the
first fob
[Music]
that's done second of all press and hold
the lock and unlock pawn on the remote
simultaneously until you hear a chime
buzzer of the door lock
cycle when all remotes are programmed
wait 60 seconds for the buzz of the
sound continuously then remove the
programmer from the obd2 port
there it is now you can pull the unit
out of your obd2 port
and to show you my level of confidence
with this device i'm going to roll my
windows up
press the lock button truck is locked
hmm the wind is picking up strong only
using my brand new key fob and walk up
to the truck and we're gonna
open it oh works great well last but not
least i'm going to try the panic button
and see if that is now working with the
truck on the new key fob
right now okay works
it works we got it we got it and i hope
you guys enjoyed my new tutorial today
on installing a keyless entry remote
on a express havana sierra silverado or
traverse
this bicycle is specifically designed
for off-road use in cars
it's only 11 260 bucks look at that
lifted bald
brand new board
[Music]
oh yeah